mr max how are you my friend
pump pump they call him pump
pump
pump
pump
gangsta for pump are you on the show are
you calling into this show from the
united states or from el salvador
i'm in el salvador what is going on on
the ground in el salvador give us a on
the ground report from the one and only
max kaiser
yeah sure so as you know the country
made bitcoin legal tender
a year ago
uh and um they are
experiencing all the benefits and
changes that come with that
uh the economy is doing very well they
printed a 10
plus gdp gain they're looking to do
uh that or more this year tourism is up
by a couple hundred million dollars they
just completed a surfing um
competition international surfing
competition that attracted people from
all over the world that brought in
millions of dollars
uh they've got forward and direct
investment coming in in the billions of
dollars
so uh that's
all happening that's very positive now
additionally
the government has decided to crack down
on gangsters
so they have
essentially
and incarcerated thousands of gangsters
and this also has a very beneficial
impact on the economy it's estimated
that the gangs are extracting about six
billion dollars a year
and this is an economy in aggregate i
think it's like a 45 or 50 billion
dollar economy so that's a lot that's a
big difference to this economy uh it's
like giving everybody a 25 to 30 percent
tax break because they're not paying the
extortion
uh for example you've got 5 000 pupusa
sellers those are the the local delicacy
that are sold on the street there's 5
000 of these around the country they're
primarily women
and so they would pay up to half of
their revenue to these extortionists to
these gangs so now they are being uh the
gangs are being wiped out so that has a
huge knock-on effect uh the confidence
people have in the economy you see
entrepreneurialism is is getting very
strong we have a venture capital fund
here called alexante capital which is
investing in local startups and we've
got an incubator starting with jimmy
song who's training up some local coders
so there's a lot of talent here we want
to germinate and feed that local coding
talent uh so that's going on and uh
it's uh it's it's it's it's all
happening you know they're having a
tremendous
tremendously positive
impact now people will say that they
bought their bitcoin at a higher price
they've got an unrealized loss on the
books last i checked it was like maybe
30 or 35 million but you know you got to
put that in the context of the of of
what's happening
throughout the economy right so without
the bitcoin law you wouldn't have those
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
tourism boost you wouldn't have all that
investment coming into the country it's
essentially the cost of a rebranding and
you know uh in the world of corporate
america and global corporations the cost
of rebranding a major corporation would
be hundreds of billions of dollars you
know certainly hundreds of millions of
dollars
so here you have a rebranding of a
country thanks to this bitcoin law and
they've got an unrealized loss on the
books of approximately 35 million but
you know as
th that that will be a net gain as
bitcoin continues to march higher
so um that's what's going on
so when you start to think about el
salvador they're creating a playbook and
that playbook uh based on many of the
metrics that you shared at the beginning
of the conversation uh seems to be
working how do you take that playbook
and get it in the hands of other
countries and are there other types of
countries that you think will be the
most receptive to this are they
developed nations developing nations
certain geographies around the world
where you say yes that's where we expect
this to uh to be adopted next
absolutely so the president here in el
salvador hosted a
a get-together of i think was 44
central bankers from around the world
mostly the global south this took place
just a couple of weeks ago and they all
came to el salvador they were down in el
zante they all got a bitcoin wallet they
were all using their bitcoin wallet
hyper bitcoinization and then they went
back to their respective countries uh
having been orange filled so the
president president buchelli is orange
killing central bankers
by the score you know dozens of them
coming to the country and getting orange
pill and then they go back to their
respective countries and they carry the
message obviously we've got the central
african republic or carr has made
bitcoin legal tenders so that's that's
happening uh in now in africa and he's
orange filled and the way he talks about
bitcoin is very very strong he's got all
the very strong talking points there uh
so you see it spreading there but the
playbook is key you know samson mao who
left block stream recently to join a
company here in el salvador that he's
starting called jan 3. he that's the
sole business model was bitcoin as a as
a service as a sovereign solution and
now he's going to other countries in
this region specifically guatemala
honduras and he is talking to higher-ups
and getting them to get on board with
making bitcoin uh legal tender so that
that playbook as you as you call it uh
is is being uh spread to other countries
particularly in this region and they the
people the folks are really receptive
because they see the effect of the the
positive impact it's had here
when you think about the average citizen
what is the path uh to educating them on
the actual asset on monetary history on
economics like how do you how far deep
down the rabbit hole do you think that
the average citizen has to go until the
light clicks and they say oh i get it
like this is something that i want this
is something that i need to use
well this you know pop this is the uh
the the always a big question you know
because bitcoin is
is is not something that
you can pick up over the weekend you
know you really have to think about it
for a while and and think deeply about
it you know for me what i always talk
about
first whenever i talk to people is the
the quality of bitcoin where it's
unconfiscated
uh so this is really unique in his
history we've never had a as a species
the opportunity to have wealth that's
fun
you know absolutely uncomplicated
and that resonates that really you know
people like that idea and the folks here
who were unbanked right 70 of the
country
before bitcoin was unbanked now 70
percent of the country is relatively
banked as they all have now the chivo
wallet they have access to bitcoin so
that was a flip you know an incredible
change and people like that idea you
know i come up to people come up to me
all the time in the street and they pick
up their show me their phone and they go
i have twenty dollars you know like i'm
like wow that's [ __ ] awesome dude uh
yeah and they know that they nobody can
take that you know this is this is
theirs it's unconfiscatable and this is
they can't be inflated away it can't be
taken from the government uh it can't be
stolen it can't be extorted uh and this
is significant the other thing is that
it's uncensorable so
this is particularly key for remittances
right so money going back from fourth
from el salvador to the u.s
this money can go and nobody can stop it
nobody can can stop that transaction
it's uncensorable so those those two key
points uh i think get into it people you
know they're that gets them over the
hump they're like well you know that
sounds good let me try it let me
download this let me get let me get
started
so there's a recent uh appearance by
michael saylor uh he went and he talked
with uh with bloomberg and he gave 10
steps that he believes will make bitcoin
a stronger asset i want to go through
each one of these 10 kind of get your
thoughts in terms of ones you agree with
ones you disagree with or ones that you
think that you can elaborate further on
uh the first one is that he says that
there's an absence of the no wash
trading rule uh which basically allows
people if bitcoin is purchased at 50 000
it drops in price you can basically sell
it buy it back you can book the loss uh
and then continue to hold the same
amount of bitcoin agree disagree good or
bad for bitcoin
yeah i'm glad you brought this up i
think this is really interesting because
michael saylor is at an interesting
point in his bitcoin experience right uh
he's now going through what anyone who's
been in this
space for like i've been in it for 11
years right started buying it at a
dollar i've been through three halvings
i've been through
four maybe five eighty percent
corrections and so michael is having his
first you know big
you know cream pie in the face uh of
volatility everyone experiences with
bitcoin at some point i think his basis
that microstrategy is 30
700 and of course they're down you know
on paper from that but um so this list
of things he came up with to try to
address what he's what he says what he
thinks is uh could be improved upon now
the wash sale trading rule uh my i would
give that you know a a i'm fairly
ambivalent about that it's like yeah
that would be kind of nice but um i mean
he's trying to avoid this hyper trading
that's going on
uh people trading without any cost
whatsoever uh into kind of the fastest
moving uh you know i'll say [ __ ] coin i
don't know you know i mean altcoin uh
and there's a tremendous amount of
social media where you see hyping of
of a meme coin and so there's no penalty
for that mass of meme coiners out there
to just jump into a new one there's no
tax penalty et cetera so bringing in a
wash sale rule would would theoretically
put a buffer between that kind of uh
murmurations as i call it pomp you know
if you ever look
up in the sky you see starlings and the
flying and they're flying in these
fantastic
constellations of birds and they
seemingly just
can
can go with thousands of birds
simultaneously that's kind of like the
altcoin market and all these traders
they're hyping on social media and they
go from very rapidly from one to the
other and they're playing this
extraordinary game
and uh so that theoretically would would
kind of put a bumper uh on that activity
so i guess i guess it's okay but but
you're you know you're opening the door
to regulation
so that's where i would say put a
caution light there
the next point that he made was that
there's 520 unregistered and unregulated
crypto exchanges uh that offer 20x
leverage and his point was that this
often leads to unprotected investors
which can lead to massive losses agree
disagree and good or bad for bitcoin
well you know again michael is somewhat
of a newbie uh you know it wasn't too
long ago when over there bit max you can
get a 100x leverage so uh 20x leverage
is moving toward a more sane environment
than 100x but um i mean obviously
again um that kind of leverage is not
consistent with
the um
kind of the guardrails that should be in
place for the average retail in investor
uh and so having access to that it's
almost guaranteed you're gonna get
wrecked um it really turns platforms
like coinbase and others that they
become more like casinos i've called
them casinos before unlicensed casinos
uh and so it has that element to it
where you're you're you're really you
know you're putting up a penny and
you're gambling on 100 on the 20x or a
30x and as you know that type of trading
is is almost guaranteed a loser uh so
i mean he's right uh in terms of um of
that kind of
existence of of uh
you know as a casino operations going on
uh he's correct again it opens the door
toward regulators so that's that would
be the downside
so the next point that he made uh was
this idea that there's 19 000
cryptocurrencies being
cross-collateralized and associated with
bitcoin uh and that currently holds
bitcoin back by comparing it to badly
managed unregistered securities uh i'm
scared to ask you but agree or disagree
good or bad for bitcoin
well this is enough this is a this is an
interesting point so you know we've been
in this for a while and that these
points are not new uh you know michael's
just discovering them because you know
because this is the learning curve
people have but uh
you know
the everything that's not bitcoin as
i've said on your show before
would come under the heading of either
relatively or absolutely
centralized versus bitcoin which is
uniquely decentralized
additionally a case can be made applying
the howie test then everything that's
not bitcoin would be an unregistered
security right so and um it also
brings about the question about senator
lumus uh in her bill that she's trying
to get through congress uh talking about
applying some regulations to
quote-unquote crypto and she does things
like she equates ethereum and bitcoin
she calls them both commodities which i
think is
false i mean you can make a case that
bitcoin is a commodity like gold but
clearly ethereum is an unregistered
security without
without any doubt whatsoever so gary
gensler over at the sec it kind of
pushed back against all this and said
hey lady you know stay in your lane uh
you don't know you're talking about
which i think is the correct correct
response but um when the
cross-collateralization
issue that he's getting at is really
really the crisis du jour i would say uh
because of what we saw with terra luna
and all these other
d5 coins that they're manufacturing that
yield
you know pomp from
kind of cross-collateralizing and
putting money to work into other defy
coins and these other default coins are
generating returns by by creating coins
out of thin air
i mean by definition that's a ponzi
scheme so a lot of that defy return is
just cross-collateralizing into
new situations that are creating coins
out of thin air and rewarding early uh
you know coin rewards et cetera again
unregistered securities uh so you that
that's definitely an issue
and here i think that
this is definitely a regulatory issue
where this definitely would require
regulatory
um
kind of um
and and you see these things for example
uh
uh
the in with luna uh these guys are are
definitely getting into big trouble i i
believe they're completely prevented
from leaving
south korea they're being held by the
police so uh you know this is this is
definitely an issue so i think with that
you know he he understands that this is
what what's
what's what's keeping the lid on bitcoin
at the moment is you've got
hundreds of billions of dollars you've
got people like sam bankman freed over
at ftx who's become a king maker by
creating these enormous
kind of cross-collateralized market
making
unregis unregulated
situations where price discovery can't
take place you know this is something
that people talked about a couple years
ago they said will bitcoin experience
the same problems gold has because
there's no good price discovery in gold
because of all the derivatives
and so wall street can of can really
decide what the price of gold should be
not the market and what sailor's
pointing out is we're seeing this now in
bitcoin you've got derivatives or d phi
that are
making
creating price discovery for bitcoin uh
and it's and it's it's it's blocking it
from from a more natural price discovery
from taking place so
i think he's got an excellent point
there and this is definitely under the
wheelhouse of the sec they're they're
definitely should be enforcing in this
case and and they're being lacks
and it's unclear why
the sec is is being lacked
so his next point uh was connected to
this which is this idea of these wildcat
banks the ability for uh centralized
platforms or uh decentralized and name
uh platforms to actually offer
unsustainable yields uh and kind of
gamify uh or or celebrate a lot of these
what uh what is your thoughts there good
or bad uh for bitcoin and do you agree
or not
well it's like a a tag on to the to the
previous point right it's just that he's
just emphasizing the same point you've
got these what he called wildcat banks
um these big platforms and they're
interrupting price discovery and they're
doing so in a way that's manipulative
and fraudulent and it's the perfect
opportunity for the for the sec to step
in and enforce the rules
and so when you start to think about his
next point he listed ignorance and fear
of the asset class as a lack of
technical know-how still terrifies many
as does media coverage telling of the
many supposed deaths of bitcoin kind of
the the sentiment the conversation the
lack of information being a problem what
are your thoughts there agree or
disagree and uh good or bad for bitcoin
well the adoption is definitely tied to
understanding bitcoin and we know that
the more you learn about bitcoin the
more of a maximalist you become
uh nobody who
learns
about bitcoin fails to become a
maximalist only people who really don't
take the time to learn about it are left
in the camp of a no coiner or a skeptic
but on this point i think what he's
missing is the global nature of bitcoin
so in the u.s
which has the u.s dollar and it has
a much different culture and the
financial markets are in a much
different place
this is a bigger problem to get through
to people who are bombarded with
so many things happening
in the financial space and the way that
that's changing uh you know i look at
how for example gambling has become
legalized with platforms um
now that that we didn't really have even
a few years ago but if you look around
the world places like el salvador the
global south place in africa the the the
need for bitcoin is so great that the
learning curve is very fast they just
get it there's a need for it and that's
where you're going to see the growth pop
you know bitcoin is really very much
going to be the global south making a
move on the global north you're going to
see uh the changing of the guard uh the
central banks the federal reserve bank
and the bank of england uh european
central bank are going to be usurped
they're going to be overtaken by this
bitcoin revolution and it's going to
come from these other countries it's not
going to be led by
the united states so i would suggest to
michael saylor that he take his message
to overseas you know get take your yacht
and sail to uh countries uh that where
bitcoin is adopted and the learning
curve is rapid because there's a real
need for it you know
throw america under the bus for now
because they're just mired in too much
other stuff these other countries
however
it's where it's happening faster because
the need is clear and and the asset is
performing brilliantly for
you know these millions of people and
soon to be a billion people and more
he made the point that we don't have a
real stable coin yet because there isn't
one that is fully regulated and approved
agree or disagree and good or bad for
bitcoin
all right this i totally disagree with
michael saylon
because when you're talking about a
regulated stable coin you're talking
about a cbdc a central bank digital
currency you're talking about usdc the
circle coin you're talking about a fed
coin you're talking about a surveillance
coin and you're you're removing
one of the best aspects of bitcoin
in that the on-ramp would be outside of
the banking system right bitcoin exists
outside of the banking system
and it's
so when you have a regulated stable coin
you're creating a regulated on-ramp to
bitcoin and defeating the purpose of
bitcoin so that and that in this in this
piece that michael saylor mentions i i i
completely disagree and i think it goes
against the ethos of bitcoin this is
something that he and i have talked
about before i i'm 182 degrees in
opposition of this idea so let me ask a
clarifying question here which is uh
regulated stable coin is different than
stable coin is your thought process that
there will be stable coins and people
will use them but they just won't be the
central bank digital currencies or like
how do you think this plays out uh do
you think these stable coins end up all
failing and nobody adopts them uh and
bitcoin is kind of the last remaining
one
well tether is working great you know
it's the biggest one out there and um
they just added the the mexican peso and
they added the british pound they have
the us dollar i believe they have the
euro
and um it's it works fine and uh it
works for the unbanked so the tether
model is fine and uh it will resist
being encroached upon by nefarious
regulators
and so when you think about that it's
really just the the regulated component
versus more of a free market stablecoin
is really where the difference in maybe
you and sailors opinion
yes
i would say that's correct yeah
it um it feels like stable coins are
going to be a thing but i think the
nuance of uh free market versus
regulated uh is up for debate right so
that makes a ton of sense his next point
was around the absence of a spot etf uh
in the united states uh we obviously
have the bitcoin futures etf we have a
short bitcoin futures etf but still no
spot bitcoin etf agree or disagree with
them here and good or bad for bitcoin
totally agree um it's unconscionable
that gary gensler and the sec would
allow this to keep going without having
a spot etf in the marketplace and by
allowing things like a futuristic
bitcoin etf to exist and the futures
based etf products are notoriously
horrible they almost never work and
they're not they're not suitable for
retail they're not even suitable for
institutions they're not they're not
suitable for anybody and yet somehow
these things have gotten into the
marketplace other countries have spot
etfs their argument that there's no good
price discovery and bitcoin
is fallacious it's the false and easily
disproved and so again you know when it
comes to the sec
it's really hard to understand who
they're working for are they working for
the open and transparent markets on
behalf of
investors or is there some other agenda
going on i cannot for the life of me
understand their reasoning behind this
it seems it seems to me to be
some element of corruption here going on
uh obviously a lot of people don't want
bitcoin to succeed because it challenges
them and it challenges the banking
system i mean is that what's going on is
there a conflict of interest because it
makes no
it makes no sense you know um
i i'm i'm an expert in this area having
invented
a virtual currency in 1996 a patented
virtual currency in market making and
securities i mean i am one of the
foremost experts in this in the world
and i i've looked at gary gensler's
reasoning on this and it doesn't add up
and in in conjunction with the other
decisions he's made as we've said
failing to enforce some of these obvious
scams i mean i really i really i really
question this guy's integrity i really
do bob
when you start to look at um the next
point that uh sailor makes here he says
that there's a lack of regulatory
guidance and support institutions that
currently must overcome
uh and he also makes points that include
the lack of insurance as well as
guidance and becoming uh involved with
the space so it's hitting on a lot of
the same points you're talking about
here agree or disagree and do you think
that more regulatory guidance would be
helpful to bitcoin
it would definitely be helpful for
michael saylor because as a corporate
officer
he has to comply with a lot of
regulations and
he's also trying to get his other
corporate ceo friends involved and
there's a lack of it for them
so
from a as an asset as a reserve asset
for a corporation
he's seeing um
a a paucity of guidance from regulators
that would help him
um
communicate with his stakeholders and
investors and to other ceos and cfos out
there that would that would be
interesting so it it it would help um
institutional or corporate adoption for
sure
ultimately it doesn't matter to bitcoin
as such
uh because it does it's a
self-regulating
entity it doesn't need regulation it
regulates itself you know bitcoin
regulates the regulators so uh it
doesn't mean in the long run it doesn't
doesn't mean anything to bitcoin but for
yeah it'd be great
for for him to be able to
on his 10ks and 10 qs refer to something
that was written by the regulators as a
to guide his
the ship of bitcoin you know that he's
trying to put together there so
definitely help him
when you start to think about uh the
macro environment right now bitcoin is
down 70
uh i think that you have lived through
maybe four or five different drawdowns
of 80 plus percent um what is similar to
past market drawdowns and what is
different about this one compared to
those past market drawdowns
i think in the past there was
a definite
lack of liquidity going on so you know
mount gox was the only exchange around
and it was incredibly buggy and
wasn't
suitable for making markets and
so when it started to blow up you had a
pretty predictable fall
in the price um other exchanges that
were dominant like bit max and others
were
were run um without much thought to
um concern about
hewing to regulatory guidelines let's
say uh i think when sailor first started
buying bitcoin
he made the comment that maybe 50
million
a day in volume was actual
bitcoin the rest was wash trading you
know bitcoin has had a wash trading
problem for years you know exchanges
trading for the in them owned their own
accounts to create stimulated volume
you see that in the nasdaq market all
the time you know nasdaq is a network of
dealers right it's not like the new york
stock exchange where you have a
specialist at this post
making a market you have a network and
that nasdaq is
for years guilty of wash trading amongst
themselves to create the painting the
tape and all these other techniques to
create the illusion of volume and to
manufacture prices and bitcoin had this
problem for years and so when the
sentiment changed you'd have an 80
drawdown because there's just no volume
there was no volume now what's different
here is that over the past let's call it
the michael sailor era of the past
several years
the volume has become legitimate and the
demand is legitimate and so the markets
are legitimate and but the the issue
here would be the layering on top of
this market of these derivatives or d
phi and cross collateralization so
that's created um
a a a an obstacle uh for for good price
discovery so that that would be the
difference but the net effect is the
same you know people
always of course ask me and ask you and
ask others for price predictions and
it's um it's an incredibly volatile
asset so it really is
incredibly difficult to make a price
direction other than just that
prediction other than to say that
what i've been saying for 11 years i can
i'll tell you the direction of bitcoin
it's up you know if you hold it for
three or f you know maybe three and a
half years anyone who's held it for
three and a half years or four years
is in the black right so if you've got a
time frame of which is not a long time
frame three and a half four years you're
going to be in the black
but i think that would be the the main
difference is that also you know in this
environment i when i was at the bitcoin
miami
22 that you know the conference the
difference between that conference and
let's say conference from 10 years ago
was the quality of the suits
right so the people on stage are wearing
you know three thousand dollar suits
back 11 years ago 10 years ago people
would show up and torn t-shirts and
there were coders and you know rarely
came out of their basement but it's the
same kind of
struggle to come to terms with this
emerging asset class
and in a lot of ways it's it's the same
uh you just have a higher grade of
speculator you have of course um the
amount of money that's been flooding the
system has increased every year for many
years now i mean we got
the the central banks have fina have
decided within the last six months to
to raise rates uh and and really put an
end to a 40-year
bull market in the bond market um so on
the macro side this is the first time
bitcoin has faced a rising interest rate
environment
uh which causes on the macro side a huge
shift in the funds uh you see for
example something like the russian ruble
is the strongest performing currency in
the world in 2022 because it's commodity
based i think
starting in february with the the russia
ukraine conflict we saw the end of a
40-year bull market in bonds and
financialization in the beginning of a
secular inflationary
move in global markets that'll be
tied to commodities you know commodities
were not a big factor for 40 years it
was financialization interest rates
extend and pretend just create more
bonds lower lower you know the coupon
rate extend the maturity that's the way
the world worked for 40 years and now
we're in a new world where suddenly the
price of stuff like energy and food it
cannot be hidden anymore it's actually
hitting people's bottom line and that's
not going to change anytime soon that's
a secular shift in the inflation in the
economy in in the globe that's going to
be with us for years not a few months
and so that's something that is new for
bitcoin
um and
ultimately it's going to do well in that
environment because
as people begin to understand that the
financialized world is crumbling uh
having this you know i've often i often
say bitcoin is a risk off
investment it's not risk on it's risk
off uh this is where you put your safe
haven cash it's hard to make that case
with the volatility the way it is but
when you have something but for all the
other reasons it's unconfiscatable
unsensible immutable you know it makes
sense it makes a lot of sense for a
billion or two billion people
out there that have been unbanked that's
where the growth is going to come that's
where the adoption is happening
so that those are the changes some some
differences some similarities
when you think of the macro environment
the fed says they're going to continue
to raise interest rates they're going to
conduct quantitative tightening they're
going to get a soft landing inflation
will come down everyone calm down and
all will be good in the world
how crazy are they and how off are they
in their thought process that they can
actually get inflation down and not push
us into a recession
you know it's uh as i said i think this
is a kind of a follow-up to what we were
just saying there so
um the fed is still thinking like the
world is similar to the way it's been
for 40 years you know starting with
greenspan you had the so-called
greenspan put you know every time
markets came down greenspan would flood
the market with more cash and lower
interest rates and that had that went
through bernanke johnny allen jay powell
they the activists fed this the model
has been with us for 40 years
and that there's no problem that can't
be solved by money printing what
happened in february
24th
with russia ukraine now
is that that model is dead
and
the price
determining factor for prices is shifted
from
the new york fed or from the
fed
to
the east
to russia russia china iran india
central america south america brazil
those countries are going to be
determining
prices going forward
and so the and the fed only makes
can only operate if the world is on a
globalized
us dollar standard but that's no longer
the case you know on february 26
two days after
russia ukraine conflict the fed seized
like 600
billion i think or million
billion in russian reserves
so you know china looked at that and
said you mean our reserves aren't safe
so
um
that was a huge
you know
self
owned you know that was that was one of
the stupidest things that anyone could
have done
so now we're on it we're in a new world
and i just think jay powell and these
guys and janet yellen they're thinking
they haven't adjusted yet but
you know markets are cruel you know and
the market price ultimately works its
way into reality
and that gas price isn't going down you
know we're talking 10 11 12 15 a gallon
for gas in the united states
you know uh and that that
do the math pop that that's not gonna
that that's a fundamental shift in the
in this
standard of living
for the united states that's just that's
just a fact because we don't have the
ability to control these markets and
prices anymore because nobody people are
dumping the dollar
the dollar is not going to be world
reserve currency and the guys with the
actual
energy
are in control so how how we how are we
going to fight that um and all the
rhetoric coming out of the the uk and
these other countries seems like people
are totally tone deaf to this reality uh
germany
let's look at another industry for
example the esg industry you know the
the climate change industry the the the
move toward renewables
well
you know that's that's completely blown
out of the water germany which was
heading toward 100 renewable is now
going back to coal
like all these countries are going back
to coal now
because
because of what's happening in the
energy markets
and so that's that's just a total shift
so i mean you're a bully i believe
you're a millennial and pomp and you
know i i think of it as being one of the
unluckiest generations ever in history
you know you kind of grew up dude
through 9 11 you've been through the
2008 crisis the subprime crisis and now
you're going to watch the us dollar lose
world reserve currency pump you know you
guys and your brothers are really the
you got you you lost the generational
lottery i can say that
max
well i agree it's been tough in the
streets
you my friend have gone through all of
those things as well plus more [ __ ]
before we were even born so i i agree
that uh there is generations that are it
almost seems like these crisis are
happening faster and faster
from a timeline perspective and i
definitely agree that they don't have as
much control as maybe they want to have
the big question is going to be how
quickly do people understand what's
occurring and those who don't understand
will likely get hurt and those who
understand uh they'll be able to kind of
position themselves uh so that they
don't have as much of an impact
well yeah that's the first point you
know i started on wall street in 1982 i
wasn't born yet max
i know but that was the peak you know
volcker took rates up to 16 17 percent
on the 10 year
so my entire professional career has
been by watching rates go down i
literally had not had to work a day in
my life bump it's just been riding this
wave for 40 years and never make a
mistake just add more debt with a lower
coupon and a bigger longer maturity it's
been great
uh but now uh that that game is over
and um
but yeah um you know the the the the
going forward i think that the
generational
rifts and all the other societal risks
so you've got what what the economist
magazine euphemistically calls
cohesion risk which is their way of
saying social unrest so in the u.s
you know people are already you know
tense
there's a number of different issues
that people are rallying and gathering
around
and there is of the cohesion of of our
society in the united states
is fraying uh and you add in higher
costs and a downshift and
the standard of life and it's only going
to get worse you know during the
globalization period
when america was shipping jobs to china
the quid pro quo there
was that okay i'm making less
but the stuff i'm buying at walmart
that's made in china like tvs and
clothes
is so much cheaper
that i don't notice that
my
quality of life is is degrading much
because even though i'm making less or i
don't even have a job
the stuff on getting a walmart is so
cheap
that i don't see much of a difference
well that's completely reversed now now
everything coming in is going to be more
expensive and your wages are still
squeezed so that it's going to be
shocking
reversion to the mean where quality of
life with standard of life is going to
take a remarkable downshift
and i you know people are people don't
like that and and they're going to be
there's going to be more unrest you know
i don't want to be like a a doom a
monger but
uh how can it not be historically any
every time you have that kind of looting
going out at the top and let's be honest
that's what that's you got to refer to
it what it is the the ability to
um
through the practices of a cantillon
effect where you're printing trillions
of dollars and keeping a thousand
dollars for a banker and giving it one
dollar to the plebs that process was
going to eventually lead to a huge
social dislocation and that's that's
what we're on the doorstep right now and
there's no way you can't print your way
out of this this is the problem you
cannot print your way out of this if
most of the world's actual population
not by your gdp but by headcount
is against you right that axis of china
russia india
um central latin america south africa
that that population is greater in
number than the ones that are supporting
the us
in its current trials and tribulations
you've got a global split here you've
got a domestic split
the leadership
is lacking but there's
i don't you know i don't want to get
into a you know a a pissing match you
know and and to throw the the president
under the bus but i mean clearly
it's not the finest political
leader that america has experienced you
know that we have leading us now and the
people on deck don't appear to be
particularly
uh ready to embrace this job either so
you have political breakdown you have
societal breakdown you have an economic
breakdown
um you know again people should be
buying bitcoin
like their life depended on it because
it does
i could literally talk to you for hours
about this stuff um we unfortunately
don't have hours though uh so one you
have to promise me you're coming back
again soon and two where can we send
people to find you on the internet learn
more about your new show learn about
your podcast and learn about what you're
doing in el salvador
oh
uh well you just find me on twitter and
i will definitely [ __ ] post on you and
troll you and uh
you know that's like the nicest guy on
twitter what do you mean
yeah i'm like i'm a sweetheart
uh
yeah you know i'm trying to get up to
half a million on twitter after 47 years
on twitter you know you and frick and
michael saylor are in the millions i'm
sitting here sucking hind tit
you know how do you guys do it what's
your secret man i mean is it just the
good looks
no listen you got to get one of these i
got a suit and tie this suit and tie
helped defeat the 2018 bear market i'm
gonna wear it until we defeat this 2022
bear market you got a suit jacket on i
gotta get you a tie like me i'm so old
thompson i remember when people used to
make fun of you because you wore the
same jacket and tie on two consecutive
interviews and these going back a few
years and they thought that i had lost
the tie but this is the only tie i own
and boy does it do wonders you know how
easy it is to pick your suit in time
yeah yeah yeah he's a good tie and a
shine get a shine on your shoes and you
can conquer the world this is america
ken not american
[Laughter]
that's it max we will see you next time
my friend later